un calme apparent en surface sur le site
de la batelière mais en coulisses la
sphère du lease a pris une autre
tournure avec cette fois ci un huissier
venu à la demande de la direction
les personnels du lycée aurait dû
finalement constater que la haute et
était terminée n'était pour l'instant
pas renouveler et aurait dû fermer leurs
établissements pour ne pas exploiter le
domaine public de façon illégale
ils ont continué à le faire et nous ont
envoyé un courrier disant que notre
convention la convention qui lie et
l'hôtel batelière
il utilise n'avait plus de fondement et
devaient être modifiés de façon
unilatérale à leur convenance
donc sachant que c'est un contrat
commercial lorsque l'une des deux
parties n'est plus d'accord avec ce
contrat nous avons donc pris acte de
leur volonté de casser ce contrat est de
le terminer puisque ils ont dit qu'ils
n'avaient plus de fondement et qu'il
voulait en modifier les termes en face à
pas question de se laisser faire et
l'huissier a été empêché de faire son
constat les deux cogérants du lys
veulent poursuivre leur activité et
attendre la décision de l'état
d'accorder une nouvelle autorisation
d'exploitation du site
il dénonce une mauvaise interprétation
de leur courrier par le biais de leurs
avocats
l'objet du courrier qui avaient été
adressées à l'hôtel batelière la
direction l'hôtel batelière était de
fait ressentir cette anomalie juridique
et de proposer une modalité de poursuite
du contrat en tenant compte du fait que
ça tarde que le nouvel out et que nous
attendons tous n'est pas encore rendue
fille n'a pas encore été rendue par le
préfet alors ils en ont tué comme
conclusion de ce courrier que le lisent
avait
idée de rompre le contrat qui les lie à
eux jusqu'au 30 novembre 2020 une
crispation biais réel chacun campant sur
ses positions avec deux côtés l'hôtel
qui vient d'annoncer un plan de
rénovation du site de 35 millions
d'euros et de l'autre le lisent 300
repas par jour et plus en odeur de
sainteté ces deux adversaires ont en
commun d'avoir fait chacun de leur côté
une demande auprès de la ddt et al et
tous deux ont encore en commun de
trouver les délais de réponse de l'état
un peu long